[Applause]
maze for three
look at the rebounding
hediger kicks it out to sharif cooper
who has the shot and he nails it sharif
cooper for three
wins the game
sharif cooper
who people say need to work on his
three-point shot is now five for eight
for behind the arc including the
game-winner steph he's a gamer
the kid just wins
broken play he steps back knocks it down
and
the pacers are stunned right now let's
watch
jalen johnson gets it to maze goes up
box out is there and everybody goes for
a good job it was made by jalen johnson
and if you're cashes you don't throw
that one
and
cooper knocks it down and cash is
stanley once you catches this one you
don't throw the ball under your basket
you gotta throw it all the way down here
if anything yes
okay so you just heard cheryl flores the
lead official say that
the shot is all right thanks steph
sharif you've had ice water your veins
your whole young career take me through
when the ball goes in your hand what's
going through your mind man it was i
knew he's down two
i knew i knew once he got the rebound i
had to get behind that line i didn't
want to shoot it two so i i ran behind
the line uh god guy willing i made it
three
all these people said your whole career
you can't shoot
so after that shot do i need to invite
you to shoot this paradigm you knock
down five threes tonight yeah man that's
what i work on um you tell me i can't do
something best believe i'm working on it
so um
hey hey
thank god you know i was able to make
shots today but i work on my game for
sure you have swagger after you make the
shot we saw a little chitter chatter
with the pacer bench take me through it
yeah i would just ask him if it looked
good so i asked him to go crazy anyone
look at me
but you know it was a good game um
credit to the pacers for a good game uh
but we got two more left so we're gonna
try to get two more wins i can imagine
right now sister tia has a nice little
text for you on your phone yeah yeah she
here she's here today so i can't wait to
go over there and you know say what's up
all right appreciate you appreciate too
all right guys sharif cooper showed up
in a big way ice water in his veins
dennis scott thank you so much thank you
sheree for stopping that was amazing